on Saturday March 18 2023 former
president of the United States Donald
Trump announced on his truth social
platform that he would be arrested the
following Tuesday
what would happen if he was arrested
how would his supporters react
and could he still run for president
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Donald Trump was arrested
now at the time we made this video it
wasn't exactly clear whether Donald
Trump would be arrested before he could
be arrested the former president would
need to be indicted meaning he'd need to
be formally accused of a crime
the crime in question is his alleged
payment of one hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in hush money to cover
up his sexual encounters
now this in and of itself is not illegal
however upon reimbursing his lawyer
Michael Cohen for paying the hush money
the record of the payment was listed as
a legal fee which according to
prosecutors means Donald Trump is guilty
of falsifying records
if Donald Trump is arrested you're sure
to see protests and counter protests
both have already started after Trump
announced on Truth social that he wanted
his supporters to protest and take our
nation back and if past high-profile
cases are any indication Trump would
likely be processed somewhere in the
district attorney's office this would
involve having his mug shot taken and
getting fingerprinted
then Trump would need to sit in a
holding area or a cell to await his
appearance before a judge
now while we can't predict the outcome
of this case most experts agree that if
he's found guilty it's likely that Trump
would only have to pay a fine this seems
more probable than a possible prison
sentence of four years
some people fear that at any point in
this process Donald Trump's supporters
might cause another incident like the
one that occurred on January 6 2021 at
the U.S Capitol
now while it is possible that Trump will
rally his supporters to protest on his
behalf it's likely that law enforcement
and officials will be braced to react
and ideally would be able to prevent
another incident
but let's say that hypothetically Donald
Trump is found guilty of a crime
could he still continue his campaign to
be re-elected as president of the United
States well yeah nothing in United
States law prevents a candidate from
running if they've been convicted of a
crime
although it would likely make his
campaign more difficult but if he did
manage to win even if he were sentenced
to jail time he could serve part of his
presidential term Behind Bars
it's hard to say with any certainty how
this potential arrest might go down
since no U.S president has ever been
prosecuted and that includes Richard
Nixon it's not impossible that our
growing political divide could spiral
out of control and that some extremist
figures could advocate for Civil War
yeah thankfully this is unlikely to
happen Civil Wars are rare and almost
never happen in wealthy Democratic
countries
what is certain though is that news
coverage of this case would be around
the clock and the political divide we're
experiencing would become much larger
and you're sure to hear much more about
it in the coming days
arresting a former president would be a
huge event but
what would happen if someone like
Vladimir Putin were to die suddenly
well that's a story
for another
what if
foreign